salut après l'amour je voudrais
m'attaquer à un autre gros morceau dans
un petit format bon il ya plusieurs
manières de comprendre la question du
sens de la vie la première qui me vient
à l'esprit c'est celle qui consiste à se
demander pourquoi on est là pourquoi
nous existons et d'anglais on voit
qu'elle se dédouble pourquoi sommes-nous
la renvoie d'abord à la cause à ce qui a
permis rendu possible ou décider de
notre existence
pourquoi sommes-nous la renvoie à la
finalité de l'existence
ici c'est la question du sens de la vie
comme direction ses sens comme dans la
phrase
le vent souffle dans ce sens s'est
demandé où va-t-on la question y at il
un sens à la vie devient vatan quelque
part est ce qu'il y a un but est ce
qu'il ya une logique derrière
l'existence mais je voudrais poser la
question un peu différent je voudrais
vous demander quel est le sens de votre
vie à vous et par là je veux dire que
nous expérimentons tous la vie selon un
certain sens ce sens là c'est ce qui
donne une tonalité une coloration aux
événements aux émotions aux idées
pour le dire autrement j'appelle ici
sens de la vie la part de notre
expérience qui est déterminé par nos
croyances métaphysique fondamentale par
exemple est ce que vous vous croyez
libre ce qui suppose de se demander
est-ce que vous éprouvez votre vie
mentale comme quelque chose que vous
contrôlez parce que comme on l'a abordée
dans plusieurs longs formats la
perception que nous avons de notre
supposée libre arbitre à définir la
manière dont nous allons percevoir le
comportement d'autrui est également le
nôtre le sentiment de culpabilité ou de
fierté par exemple n'est pas quelque
chose d'anodin on peut dire qu'ils
colorent nos interactions où le rapport
à soi
je reconnais qu'il est très difficile
d'identifier quel est ce sens que nous
donnons à notre vie c'est que nous
n'avons pas l'habitude de questionner
directement les fondements métaphysique
de nos croyances du quotidien c'est
quelque chose que je regrette j'ai un
brouillon le script de vidéos inachevée
depuis plus d'un an qui s'intitule où
est passé d'un métaphysique parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'on ne fait aucune
place à ces questions surtout dans les
milieux sceptiques ou intellectuelle on
a tendance à caricaturer des croyances
religieuses voix a revendiqué à
l'athéisme sans nuance et sensibilité du
genre moi je crois au fait c'est tout
les gens qui disent ça ne se sont
sûrement jamais demandé ce qui constitue
un fait ni ce qui fonde et justifie
d'ailleurs le concept d'expérience
cette confiance affirmée dans la science
surtout un dévouement pour une certaine
vision de la science qui rappelle le
positivisme un dépouillement quasi
religieux d'ailleurs ce qui ne manque
pas d'ironie puisqu'il est régulièrement
à signer avec une assurance totale comme
s'il n'y avait pas de place pour le
doute comme si rien n'avait de valeur au
delà de la pure description de
phénomènes naturels
il existe pourtant tout un champ
scientifique comme la cosmologie dont
les cheminements touche explicitement
des questions métaphysiques max tegmark
un physicien suédois soutient par
exemple que l'univers est une structure
mathématique je ne veux pas dire que
l'univers est descriptible par une
structure mathématique mais que
l'univers est une structure mathématique
c'est une croyance idéaliste qui
rappelle certaines affirmations
platonicienne
je pense que croire un truc pareil
sincèrement ça change je sens qu'on
donne à sa vie pour le dire autrement
imaginez un égalisateur sur lequel se
trouvent toutes les émotions possibles
et imaginables à chaque moment de votre
vie vous vous trouvez dans une certaine
configuration effective on pourrait dire
qu'un événement qui ne fait pas bouger
légalisa turret un événement qui a très
peu voire aucune signification vous
voyez dans les films américains quand
quelqu un tronçon de sa chérie et tente
de la rassurer en lui disant eddine mean
anything c'est comme pour dire ça
comptait pas ça implique que c'était pas
très engageant emotionnellement que
c'était du sexe sentiment que ce n'était
pas bouleversant que ça ne change rien à
ce que cette personne ressent pour son
ou sa chérie ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
rapport entre les croyances et les
mouvements de l'égalisation qu'est ce
qui motive ces mouvements quelle logique
fils t-il qu'est ce qui fait que pour
telle personne un événement x
produira-t-elle ensemble d'affect et
pour tel autre personne un ensemble
différent avec un petit travail
respectif on peut pressentir certaine
logique qui détermine le sens de notre
vie en se posant certaines questions des
questions qui testent le sens de la vie
parce qu'il s'agit de se demander ce qui
changerait si on adoptait un autre
fondement métaphysique par exemple
qu'est ce que ça changerait dans votre
manière d'éprouver le quotidien si vous
vous mettiez à croire en dieu ou au
contraire si vous cessiez de courant du
qu'est ce que ça changerait pas votre
manière d'éprouver le quotidien si vous
étiez convaincu de vivre dans une
simulation qu'est ce que ça changerait
dans votre manière d'éprouver le
quotidien si vous étiez fataliste si
vous pensiez que tout est écrit d'avancé
que vous n'avez aucune marge de
manoeuvre sur votre futur qu'est ce que
ça changerait dans votre manière
d'éprouver le quotidien si vous
appreniez que l'univers est cyclique que
tout ce qui s'est passé aura lieu encore
et encore à l'infini qu'est ce que ça
changerait à vos impatiences à vos
frustrations à vos désirs à vaureilles
ces questions me fascine et vous laissez
moi des commentaires pour partager vos
croyances et la manière dont elles des
familles une le sens de votre vie salut